Welcome back to part number 3
about parsers. We
have defined some very simple parsers.
Then we developed in the second part
a few parsers to use several
parsers in a row. And
even though the parsers that we have
defined are very primitive
they are already powerful enough to parse
arithmetic expressions that have
deep structure.
And that is what we are going to do
in this last
part of this lecture on parsing. Here are
the expressions that we are going to parse.
We want to have simple expressions that
are built from simple digits with
addition and multiplication.
An expression can be parenthesized
and moreover we want * to bind stronger
than + and we want both of them to
associate to the right. What does
that mean? If we have a+b+c
we want to parse that as a+(b+c)
and if we have a+b*c
we want to parse that as a+(b*c).
So this is fairly conventional
just arithmetic expressions. So how are
we going to
implement this using those very very
simple parsers
that we defined in the previous two
sections?
Well, the first thing that we are going
to do is we are going to write down
a grammar for these expressions.
If you have taken a
course in compilers or formal languages or
you look in any programming language
definition in the back, where the grammar
of the language is defined
you will find a grammar that looks very
similar to this. So
there's an expression, there's a term
there's a factor
and these three productions are used to
encode
the binding of the expressions.
The fact that these are defined like this
in this recursive form
encodes
the associativity. An expression
is a term plus an expression
or a term. A term is a factor times a term
or a factor. And a factor is a digit or
a parenthesized expression.
And a digit is a digit. So that's where
the recursion bottoms out. But as I said
this is real standard encoding
of expressions in a grammar.
Now what we are going to do is we are
going to massage
this grammar a little bit. And again
it's also very common. Every book
on compilers will do this and often
grammars are defined like this. The
way we will do it is saying
an expression is a term followed by
plus and an expression or the empty string
or epsilon, this is the empty parser
that doesn't recognize anything.
And then term is a factor
followed by * term or
again the parser that only recognizes
the empty input.
So if we take this, we can
now immediately translate
this definition here, which is recursive
here:
an expression is defined in terms of an
expression
but there's first the term and then it
recognizes the plus.
Expression recognizes a term
then a plus and then an expression
and then it returns
the term plus the expression, and
then this one
is the empty case.
So you will immediately
return the term.
And the same for term and the same
for factor. So in some sense that
encoding of the grammar
has a one to one correspondence
with this recursive
expression here. And that's the nice
thing.
In some sense these parser
combinators, as they are called, are like
an internal DSL. So instead of writing a
grammar
in some externally defined language
like Yacc and Lex.
compiling that into another language
we can do this all within Haskell and
then use all the facilities
of Haskell to define helper functions
and so on.
Parsers are one of, I think
the most elegant
internal DSLs that you can imagine.
And as I said, you can do very
sophisticated parsers
and you can push this idea pretty far.
The next thing is we are going to define
an evaluator
that takes a string
tries to parse the string as an
expression
and then returns the resulting value.
And if we go back here
you see that we are already
evaluating the expression
as we are parsing it, because we are
parsing the plus
operator and then we are taking the term
and we are
adding the result of parsing the
expression.
The result of this is already a parser
of Int.
So we are not even creating a parse tree.
We are immediately, as we are parsing,
evaluating
the expression. So that's what you see
here: we parse the expression
given the input, since this
returns either a
empty list or a singleton list. If it
returns a singleton list we take the
head, so we take that value.
We take the first element, which was the
number and then there's the rest
of the string. If this fails to parse the
head will throw an error
and this whole thing will fail. So let's
see here.
If we are parsing 2*3+4
that should return 2 times 3 is 6,
plus 4
is 10, and guess what?
That's the value we get. And if we are
evaluating
2*(3+4), what we should get
is 3 plus 4 is 7, times 2 is 14.
Guess what? It behaves as expected.
In the exercises you will do
several things with parsers.
And in particular, one of the things
that you will do
is you will have to implement the
sequencing operator
that we used, but didn't define.
We have defined various operators on
parsers, but one of the essential ones
this sequential composition, we didn't
define
and that's the main exercise of this week.
Happy hacking.
Make sure you do your homework and see
you next week.
Bye bye.